[Music]
three two one action
recently in Pasadena California I've
been there yeah we've all been there
please not a corona story no she can
watch it later yeah watch it back anyway
that was my favorite Steve moment of my
life okay Dan so there was there was
there okay there was a swarm of very
aggressive please an estimated 30,000 to
40,000 bees a lot of babies in one have
you heard they're together
I'm a flower tree what's a big tree that
blossoms with lots of flowers we got it
there's like a broccoli of a tree right
okay what color it's when the flowers
come out it blossoms with white dance
pretty and the whole tree sounds like a
beat so when you get close to it it
sounds like these I would help the whole
thing what's the tree look like they're
in the wintertime green California it
doesn't the leaves don't fall it's one
of those trees yeah but the whole play
the whole thing I was like out there and
I was listening and I was like is there
a weed whacker and then the whole tree
was [ __ ] filled with those [ __ ]
maybe they don't even call ours and
they're all bees just retaining like
their flowers in little clusters scary
do when I was a kid I got a [ __ ] net
from the dollar store and so I was gonna
go like hunt fireflies and [ __ ] because
I lived in East Coast and fireflies is
amazing by the way we have lows okay so
so there during the day I was just
walking around my [ __ ] net because
I'm bored as hell and I see this
beautiful like it's like a neon looking
bug it was neon like neon blue and
and read and I was like I got a [ __ ]
catch this bug so I'm trying to get it
with my net I follow it all the way to a
bush and then I get attacked by like
[ __ ] 14 Yellowjackets Oh in my neck
okay Mac neck neck neck bat so that was
like the little sexy one [ __ ] luring
you in know what that first book it was
a yellow jacket mess it was a jacket
with a green she put on her green jacket
let me go [ __ ] temp steamed green I
come over here it was a Brazilian
tourist trap that's why I need you think
of that Steve green neon I pictured this
boys like Christopher Robin inches you
have to go to a hospital
oh no thank thankfully I'm not allergic
to bee so it was yes don't like 20 times
well hello jacket or knit or something
right they're not you're not bees right
yeah there was
yeah wasp yeah and they just they just
keep [ __ ] they don't stop man they
[ __ ] get you in were you like oh I
got stung by 14 times well you hold her
the net I was running home and [ __ ]
dude whatever the [ __ ] that was so funny
when it's far away run hilarious
so this story you back to the story
there were initially someone called 911
about a person being stung by a bee near
Pasadena City College and so when first
responders got there they got attacked
like insanely attack first responders
did yes Oh like firefighters policemen
can you imagine the whole Pasadena
Police Department doing this stuff you
looking full SWAT gear like it ready to
take over the world but they go inside
real good stuff yes so the first
firefighter that got there he usually
went to go check it out
then he's like a [ __ ] or an episode he
just started getting attacked like crazy
so he started running to back to the
vehicle to try to take cover any broader
but then he remembered that his partner
inside it was allergic to being so he
couldn't go inside so he's just stood up
you should have kicked the partner out
so he could drive away no but the
partner would be luck buddy yes she just
jumped on the fire truck and they
would've drove off all right the hose
getting about 15 to 20 bees oh my god
dude backup arrived and then yeah as a
backup arrived and then the cop were
like drop your weapon around the bees
format they form a gun yeah oh we gotta
put you right up for ya oh they actually
do that
the when remember that scene when he
goes up in the in the tree and then he
was like he covers himself in mud cuz he
got to get the balloon to go up and then
the bees who did way mijo one knows
where you're talking and then she slowly
go bunch of bees and he goes I do
remember what I wanted to leave you
hanging well I keep playing the scene in
my head the longer you leave me hanging
my favorite so then that's when the
firefighters the fire department came
and they called him police to to like
why don't they call beekeeper I go no
these are wrong people
eventually like this is our tourist
picture you'd be [ __ ] beekeeper yeah
and who knows the number of beekeepers
you know I'm saying it's not like they
have an emergency Google we have a
computers no time for that geo it's an
emergency you're no help cops take you
said more innocent people it's a [ __ ]
the battlefield the unprepared goog-411
my crime scene okay come sit police it's
my job now
CIA comes in it's my job now he [ __ ]
beekeeper is contaminating my crime
scene
yeah I hope these beekeepers their
emergency vehicle is a big B that'd be
pretty cool speak
honey come what yeah no one be know that
deal the cops the police should have a
car that's just like a big badge I wish
things were like that opens up it's like
it flaps every minute shows the bad
going door yeah yeah a giant donut like
an Oscar Mayer Moby oh but oh
or a pig on how you gonna make fun of me
now I'm literally in a pig car I'm
owning it brawl guess what bro it
doesn't hurt me anymore
that's the siren ok back to the story
responders ended up using foam and co2
extinguishers to disperse the beef Oh
zombies were about they froze the
[ __ ] with the phone they use
smoke on bees man subdue your bees these
[ __ ] animal Wow what do they do did
they use raid well I just told you with
these these foam and co2 extinguishers
oh I don't know they can die from that
well somebody [ __ ] up yeah so then
that's when they were saying that they
were trying to get the bees to just fly
away and disappear that they don't want
to leave those bees attacked a police
officer gl you know no what did the
police offer do farmers oh if I meant
that's the I don't know they could die
from bone they should have just drove by
with like um like a float with the
flowers in shape or it would have to
call me a little bit like oh you could
move them out of the Pasadena pod Ibiza
moving like
nevermind that's really good to take in
the Sun value some [ __ ] yeah so
eventually a beekeeper removed the BCC
the beekeeper would have done it okay
fine you got your beekeeper already
happy but this is what like 40,000 bees
right that means a lot of them came out
and they'd formed a whole [ __ ]
country together it's very much yeah
then they were saying that it was it was
kind of like a movie scene like just
seeing all this black cloud yeah I would
have been laughing no look what I can
yell don't [ __ ] kind of saintly that
there were two fire fighters one police
officer two civilians that ended up
going to the hospital to be treated
there were other people that got stung
but they declined medical assistance hmm
so they were saying that these they're
like Steve they're not [ __ ]
no [ __ ] I'm not gonna go further all
been stung by bees oh hell yeah
never never I don't want to just you
know couple times psychic that stung
before us well Mia you got somebody
Yellowjackets too but also bees as well
I stepped on a bee you guys never got
stung just [ __ ] around outside that's
no baby but I get it was that how was
that the beach are you logics you seem
like you'd be allergic good yeah you
look everything baby you just you always
have random nosebleeds I'm not allergic
to bee stings how would you know if
you're alone how would you know
stung dude I might be allergic yeah we
need eyes he knows yeah if I get stung
and awesome my throat closes up in my
dojo get prescribe one of those things
that [ __ ] did you need an EpiPen
he's medically a pain in the ass
interesting pollen and cats okay so like
I feel like if you're allergic to pollen
then you know ladies cuz that's like
they love it friends yeah but I mean
there's no logic I like your son I've
only been stung once on my finger when I
was eight years old with a plastic golf
club and I like hit a tree and I think
Abby was on it and stung
my finger my ankle and I didn't even
realize I got the song until later and
it was like ready all swollen and like
itchy you know because I was in the
middle of shopping and my sister tells
me oh you're not some way beyond like
when Shopaholic yeah you shop until you
drop in yeah so you got stung on the
ankle and when you stepped on the be at
the Mia yeah it's an unlucky foot for
real was it sleep late no damp or be at
the beach that was like chilling tanning
on the beach I can come ruin it down in
the sand pacing up just like the beach
looking for the stores trying to shop
anyway back to these bees they were
saying that these were these bees they
were Africanized bees African eyes oh
good eye African killer bees yeah so
they were saying that so the term
Africanized bees is a term used to refer
to a hybrid of the African honey bee and
the European honey bees and so as
interracial be colonized bees they were
saying in the 90s listen they didn't
want to come here I'll say that exactly
nobody talks about it they're saying
they have a nickname of the killer bee
but that is an over hype of the danger
that they pose it's just that this term
gives the impression that bees are out
to kill when there are actually just
defending I wonder where that term came
from the [ __ ] you change on the media
Puckett talked about killer bees African
Killer Bee ass for like years that was
in the 90s and then they also they kind
of associated with black people that's
why they didn't like it no cuz because
they're from Africa that are more
aggressive their killer bees I heard
their dominican bees so many kidding I
heard they could dance for you too
oh yeah I know those bees look way older
than their own baseball they should have
the Asian bees because the Asian bees
will do like math really really good
that's time I'll be very aggressive
fly in a straight line either but they
also don't like themselves because
they're bees
[Laughter]
[Music]